when this man says he wants to uh come
on and promote anything or take my call
in any way shape or form the answer is
uh an emphatic yes 18-time all-star
i'll say that again 18 times i made the
all-star game
18-time all-star baseball
hall of famer and his book one tough out
fighting off life's curveballs is now
available
uh in paperback and still swinging is a
weekly podcast that's going to be
starting later on this month with a man
who's now
taking to twitter and tweeting like a
high schooler getting ready for the prom
he is baseball hall of famer rod carew
how are you doing rod
pretty good rich you you've been
tweeting
enjoy that conversation with you and
richard that was that was good back in
the day we just replayed that for our
tv only audience just getting ready for
our radio audience to return here with
you and
and one of the things i talked about
with reggie rod
four summers ago was seeming to be
just a new advent in the in in major
league baseball
that exit velocity was something so
crucially important for somebody's
uh ability to hit in major league
baseball or worthiness to hit major
league baseball and contact
making contact was becoming more and
more extinct now it seems to be
an epidemic in in major league baseball
what was your exit velocity rod you know
i don't know
i didn't even think about that i just
thought about
hitting the ball and hopefully it was
going to land on the green stuff
in fair territory right i mean it just
seems that these days it's it's a
different style of hitting what do you
see when you watch major league baseball
these days rob well you know you're
right there uh
to me the longest walk was uh on the on
the field was
home plate back to the dugout dragging
my bat if i struck out
today it's a norm you know everybody
does it
they don't worry about it uh and
everybody's so caught up in the
statistics that they're given out there
about
the different things that uh that's
going on offensively
today and yeah you know um there are a
lot of kids that
aren't home run hitters that are trying
to hit the ball in the air too much
not realizing that there nobody sits up
in the air unless
someone misses one in the sun
uh i don't like it uh but young players
today
it seems like it doesn't bother them
what do you mean that the longest walk
was from uh the batter's box back to the
duggar
after striking out oh what do you mean
by man i'll tell you
there are so many things that went that
would go through your mind
how did i miss that pitch how does that
how did i let him get to two strikes
you know what was i thinking you know
all those little things and uh
i don't like to have those thoughts in
my mind i i just want
to go back and have the positiveness
that well
you know maybe he got me out now and
i'll get him the next time well and then
part of the issue
today as well rod uh rod crew here on
the rich eisen show
is not only is there just a uh i guess a
lack of shame over
uh missing a pitch and striking out
but there's now a whole conversation
about what pitchers are putting on
baseballs and how baseball's cracking
down
on it um let's just uh let's be real
here
were were pitchers putting stuff on
baseballs when you were
playing ron oh yeah they they used uh
sandpaper they use uh uh thumbtacks
they use everything you know and
especially gaylord so i finally told
gaylord i said
you can throw me whatever you want i'm
just gonna try and hit it on the dry
side
you know but it's a long
history of the game um
and i don't know if you're going to take
it away from these guys
from the pitching part but if you can't
control that pitch if there's
some type of substance on it you know
you could hit someone in the face or
it's someone in the head uh just like
what happened to uh conigliero that year
that he got hit in the face
that uh ended his career so you know
you wouldn't have a problem with with
pitchers putting stuff
on the baseballs in order to get some
sort of a grip
is what you're saying rod no i yes i
okay
didn't bother me i didn't think about
those things you know um
i figure even if he does if he gets it
over the plate
there's a good chance that i can make
contact with it put it in play
and get a base hit or two so um
doesn't bother me and and you know it
when it's
cold especially i used to love
hitting in the cold because pitchers
could not get
a real grip to throw their good breaking
balls good curve balls of sliders
so you saw a lot more fastballs in the
in the early part of the season so
all you had to do was go up to the
fastball and
you know you were gonna get get a couple
out of you know if we threw you
uh three pitches all three might be
fastballs so
i was a dead fastball hitter so i was
just looking for that
well now these days though rod um
pitchers are putting a substance on on a
glove
allegedly reportedly supposedly uh and
then eventually on the baseballs
that that that um contractors used to
to mold cinder blocks together called
spider tack
would you have a problem with that i
mean is there is there i guess a line
uh between giving pitchers the ability
to get a grip that's necessary uh
for them and also for the hitter's
safety similar to the what a hitter
would use
in pine tar to get a good grip on the
base on the bat
is there a line that they that that can
be crossed to put
something considerably different than
than what you
saw back in your day rod or no well you
know
what i saw back in my day was guys
running stuff
up and down the creases of their pants
or on their belt
or in their belt buckle on their hats
you know so
they they had the opportunity to do all
that stuff and still
uh maintain some kind of safety
in the game without thrilling somebody
or hurting somebody
uh so you know you also have to
not take too much away from the pitchers
you know give them the opportunity
to be able to hold on to the ball uh and
and get a good rotation on the spider or
breaking ball so
you know i just hate the complaining
today and just go out there and play
ball and um
see what you can hit and and just try
and hit the pitch
it just seems it's tougher to hit stuff
these days shifts
did there do you ever get a shift rob
did you ever get a shift rod carew
no i i would love
them to shift on me especially since i
hit the ball
more up the middle into left field um
then i would become a pull hitter and
just try and hit the ball on the ground
and try and and beat out some
interesting hits but
uh you know the shift i hate that they
have today i hate
because you have a guy in right field
uh second baseman moves out to right
field
and you know they're taking a lot of
basis away from
from left and hitters and people are
paying money to see these guys come up
and
you know hit the ball well to center
field and left field
and get their their share of hits but um
i would if i was the commissioner yes i
would say
you go five feet off the infield grass
and that's
it right and then and then if you're if
you're designated as a shortstop
third baseman you cannot be stationed to
the right
of second base from the point of view of
behind home plate
and second base in first base vice versa
and that's it you can't you can't move
it around but
i guess we're kind of uh you know
circling around
what is the issue with baseball in my
mind today rod guru
is that you know i know that the
commissioner was focused so much on the
length of games and pace of play but
it's the
it's the pace of action it's the it's
it's the amount of action that
that that is missing you're seeing a
bunch of innings where there's two
runners on because of a walk and uh
two outs because of a strikeout and
nobody's put a ball in play
over the span of about five minutes and
part of that is not just
a shift but it's also a significant
focus on exit velocity like we talked
about at the top of the show and then
whatever the pitchers are putting on
baseballs i mean we saw six no hitters
in the first six weeks of the season
rod and that's that's what i'm saying i
guess you know is
is maybe a little bit of less of
everything that i've just mentioned
would be helpful yeah but that's true
and um
you know you've got to you've got to
tell
kids that can't hit the ball out of the
ballpark that they have to make
adjustments
they have to learn to go the other way
uh you don't see that
in today's game and so they're pulling
the ball a lot
uh hitting hitting balls right into the
shift
and um i i've seen so many games
where they should have done the job but
they're not concentrating on
uh doing the job moving the runners from
second to third how many ways can you
score
uh from third base with uh one out or no
odds
you know uh from second base it's gonna
be hard to
to score on a fastball uh to give you
another run
but something should be
done or equals out for both the pitchers
and also the offensive side of the game
rod carew author of one tough out
fighting off life's curveballs available
in paperback for
folks who who may not know your full
story and want to maybe learn more about
it curveballs you're not just referring
to obviously
the 12 to 6 variety correct that we're
snapped off your way
in the batter's box yeah right you know
uh richard
actually gave the gave me the name for
the book
because i was going to have him write a
little excerpt
on on the front page and so when he said
tough out i said oh okay great you know
you've given me the the the name of the
book
and you know i appreciate it because i
played with reggie i played against him
and he saw
uh saw me as a hitter that um i didn't
give up
you know i battle all the way through
the at-bat so um
i appreciate it but it's a good book you
know it talks about my upbringing
it talks about my youngest daughter
dying from leukemia
and it also talks about um the situation
that i went through
with having to get a new heart and
it's a book i think that will help
people and let people understand
that um you know heart disease is like
the number one killer in this country
and they have to start taking care of
themselves i
was fortunate because i had one i had a
widowmaker and usually
you don't live from that so um
uh get advice and and what you need to
do to take care of your ticker otherwise
it's going to stop
thinking and you're not going to be here
with us
so i've joined with the american heart
association and trying to spread the
word
uh because i i see too many
younger people uh that are having heart
problems and uh
they need to pay attention a lot more
just so much to learn about you
and about life through the uh now
paperback version
of one tough out fighting off life's
curveballs
who's the best hitter you ever saw rod
ever
would be who well the guy one guy that i
played with tony oliver
because he could do so much you know he
could take the ball to the left field
hit the ball out
of the park to left field center field
or right field
and he was just a tough out you know
[ __ ] would tell you that
um they're just they would just hope
that if they throw it down the middle
that he'd make an out but um he
we roomed together for about 12 years
and so i learned a lot from him uh
i remember when i first came up you know
the video
system wasn't in yet so we had a little
bellanow camera
that we would uh take pictures of uh
of us during the course of the game then
we'll go go back to the hotel pull the
sheet off the bed
put it up on the wall and watch
ourselves head
and so we were able to see some of the
things that we were doing that
um we shouldn't have been doing but uh
tony oh is
to me one of the best hitters that that
i ever played with
or that uh that i saw as a young young
player and i got i mean uh we're seeing
a photograph of him on on screen
um as you were talking about him uh rod
and he's a left-handed hitter he doesn't
have any batting gloves on he's not
wearing the armor
on his right you know on his right arm
so he could lean over the zone like all
the stuff that we're seeing these days
it's just
old school and
you know it's just i mean i i don't know
i mean they're talking about moving the
mound back because they're trying
i don't know it just seems that we need
an ejection of this it is
leave the game the way it is you know uh
bob gibson and drysdale and
colfax and all those guys are just says
oh i'm gonna test this and see if i can
break it you know all the armor
that there were uh that tells me that
you're afraid to get hit
and it tells me you don't know how to
get out of the way
of the pitch if it wasn't inner half of
the the uh
batter's box so um
they want to stand on top of the plate
then they need to get drilled and backed
off a little bit
so you're saying rod uh you know bob
gibson rest his soul and others that you
have spoken to on this subject matter to
say that they would you know colfax that
they'd come up and in and they'd see it
they they try and break that
armor see if they can test it they've
said that you didn't see
you didn't see us wearing that stuff
back then we might the only thing we
wore
were batting gums but all the stuff that
these guys are coming up with
no no not at all
by the way and let's just talk about the
here now rod you seem to be enjoying
twitter quite a bit
i've noticed you've been tweeting quite
a bit these days you like it you know my
son got me out of the dark ages you know
right and so uh he has me doing this he
said that
it's good for you gives you an
opportunity to
um stay in the game uh talk to fans
answer questions and and so i said okay
maybe i'll try to see what happens and
so far it's been uh
successful so yes it has we're just yeah
we're just gonna keep going at it
at rod carew underscore 29. oh i would
be remiss if i did not ask you this
question
uh your thoughts on a subject or a
certain individual
here in southern california who plays
for the angels
ohtani is absolutely one of the most
talented individuals i've ever laid my
eyes on i'm trying to tell my 12
10 and seven-year-old that who we are
seeing and what he is doing
is truly uh once in a century
type material that we are seeing what do
you think of
of of watching him pitch the way he
pitches and then hit the way that he
hits
rod you know it's it's amazing rich uh
uh i love to watch him hit and once he's
steady in the batter's box and he's not
you know coming off the ball a little
bit
he's going to get better you know and
that's great he can take you out of the
ballpark
any any part of the field but
when he does hit the ball he hits the
ball with some authority
uh and he drives the ball real well
he runs good and then on the pitching
side
you know he's got he's got a great arm
and um
he's just doing a fabulous job for the
angels right now
i hope he keeps it up because he seems
to be a good kid
and you enjoy seeing
young players doing things like that bo
jackson was
the the other guy that i thought uh
could have done
you know the same thing playing football
and baseball and
and and doing good at uh
at both uh venues so it's great to see
otani
and wherever he goes he's he's drawing
people to the park he's
uh he's becoming a a hero you know
and love kids uh that's all i think
about you know
shohei hotani i love it too
and so you look at him and you think
he's pulling off the ball a little bit
huh rod crew
you looking at him yeah you know
sometimes he slides that back foot and
and then when he does instead of keeping
his firm on the ground
when he when he slides it back a little
bit you know it just
throws him off of balance and um
he sometimes ends up pulling off the
pitches that i think
that he should be hitting okay i love it
rod
truly appreciate this congrats on the
book uh enjoy your
pod when you start it right starts later
on this this month
still swinging yes yes sir absolutely uh
i look forward to hearing it watching it
people
um you know uh listening to everything
you want to lay down
so i appreciate it congrats on the book
in paperback and let's
continue these talks appreciate it thank
you very much richard
and thanks for having me on it's great
talking to you anytime that's rod carew
right here
on the rich eisen show
told gaylord perry throw the ball
however you wish i'll hit the dry
side of it
[Laughter]
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here